tenemos tres series geométricas
distintas y lo que quiero es que pienses
cuáles de estas convergen y cuáles
divergen y recordemos que una serie
converge si tiende a un valor finito y
divergentes y su valor tiende a más o
menos infinito que es decir se hace muy
grande ahora te invito a que hagas una
pausa y que pienses cuáles de estas
convergen y cuáles de éstas divergen
ok entonces vamos a recordar qué es lo
que pasa con estas series geométricas lo
que vimos en un vídeo anterior es que si
el valor absoluto de la proporción común
está entre 0 y 1 es decir este sí si es
mayor que 0 y menor que 1 entonces la
serie geométrica converge en caso
contrario divergen muy bien entonces
vamos a ver vamos a manipular esto
algebraica mente porque no está dado de
la forma tradicional verdad un número
por una proporción como un elevado a la
enésima está un poquito disfrazado así
que vamos a manipular esto tenemos 5 a
la n menos 1 déjeme ponerle un poco más
a cada 5 a la n 1 a que es igual pues lo
podemos ver como 5 a la n por 5 a la
menos 1 verdad esto utilizando leyes de
los exponentes ahora esto será igual a 5
a la n iv 5 a la a la menos 1 es uno
entre 5 así que ya tenemos esto
y luego si lo sustituimos aquí en donde
tenemos nuestra serie tendremos algo así
como 5 a la n entre 5 esto corresponde a
5 a la n 1 por 9 decimos elevado a la n
ahora lo que podemos hacer es agrupar lo
que tiene como exponente n y tener
tendremos un quinto que multiplica a 5
por 9 5 por 9 sobre 10 y todos ellos
iván elevados a la n así que ya tenemos
aquí bien distinguido quién es nuestra
proporción como sería bueno voy a
hacerlo con este mismo color sería este
número de aquí adentro es nuestra
proporción común y es 5 por 9 son 45
entre 10 son 4.5 entonces su valor
absoluto es mayor que 1 y por lo tanto
esta serie divergen
muy bien entonces vamos a ver si ya sí
ya entendiste más o menos cómo trabajar
estos problemas ahora sí vuelve a ser
una pausa y de cómo resolverías
los dos si no pues bueno vamos a vamos a
continuar ahora tenemos tres medios a la
n por 1 entre 9 a la n 2 muy bien pero
uno entre 9 a la n más 2 lo podemos ver
como 1 entre 9 a la n por 9 al cuadrado
ok esto de aquí 1 entre 9 a la n 2 es 1
entre 9 a la n por 9 cuadrada ok
entonces nuevamente nosotros podemos
factorizar o bueno agrupar todo lo que
está elevado a la n lo demás queda fuera
entonces tendremos fuera 1 entre 9 al
cuadrado que es 1 entre 81 que
multiplica a 3 medios a la n que
multiplica a 1 entre 9 a la n verdad 1
entre 9 a la n 1 a la n entre 9 a la n
pero 1 a la n es 1 entonces justamente
tendremos este número de aquí y ahora
podemos agrupar todo lo que está elevado
a la n y tendremos 1 entre 81 que
multiplica
3 x 1 que son 3 sobre 2 por 9 que son 18
bueno todavía podemos incluso
simplificarlo verdad porque tendremos
que podemos cancelar un 3 con un factor
3 del 9 y nos queda 1 entre dos por tres
que son 1 sobre 6 a la n muy bien
entonces otra vez ahora ya tenemos aquí
nuestra proporción común y es un sexto
su valor absoluto de un sexto es más
chico que 1 y por lo tanto ésta converge
converge muy bien vámonos con el último
ejemplo tenemos esto y bueno simplemente
vamos a sustituir estos dos a la n entre
3 a la n por 3 a la menos 1 muy bien
entonces
1 entre 3 a la menos 1 es lo mismo que 3
esto es lo mismo que 3 que multiplica a
2 a la n sobre 3 a la n iv esto será
igual a 3 x
dos tercios elevado a la n muy bien
entonces esto de aquí es la proporción
común es más chica que uno y por lo
tanto convergen entonces en los casos
estos dos casos el rosa y el azul son
aquellos en donde converge y por
supuesto nos dará un valor finito